Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Z.T. werden wir in den Medien
als Umweltzerstörer
oder Bienenmörder dargestellt.
Wenn du Pflanzenschutzmittel
ausbringst, bist du der Dumme.
Ich bin in einem Dilemma,
ich glaube, die meisten Bauern.
Es gibt Studien, die sagen,
dass die Fruchtbarkeit der Männer
schlechter sei,
wenn Pestizide gespritzt werden.
Daran sollen wir
auch noch schuld sein?
Man spritzt seit 40 Jahren
Pflanzenschutzmittel.
Ich habe auch drei Kinder,
es ist alles okay.
Mit was du begonnen hast - da war
viel aus Giftklasse 2 und 1 dabei.
Mit dem Totenkopf drauf,
das weiss ich noch.
Das haben wir alles nicht mehr.
Heute hat man eigentlich
Zuckerwasser. Es ist wahr.
Ich glaube, die Massenproduktion
von Lebensmitteln
hat mich krank gemacht.
Die Agrochemie ist Teil davon.
Ich träume von einer Welt,
in der man essen kann,
ohne sich zu vergiften.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
In den 70ern, 80ern und 90ern
wurde gesündigt.
Aber man wusste es auch nicht.
Man hätte schon früher sagen können,
dass dieser Stoff
nicht unproblematisch ist.
Wann früher?
In den 80er- oder 90er-Jahren
hätte man das erkennen können.
Für einen Chemiker
ist es eigentlich klar.
Aber primär ist es
Aufgabe der Zulassungsstelle.
Dann haben die Zulassungsbehörden
klar versagt?
* Bestürzende Klänge *
Es sind sicher Fehler passiert.
Ich mache diesen Film zu Pestiziden
und habe gedacht,
ich starte bei mir selbst.
Sie sind Toxikologe - macht es Sinn,
meine Belastung zu testen?
Ganz bestimmt.
Wir wissen, dass Pestizide
bei fast jedem vorhanden sind.
Kann das eine Gefahr sein, wenn
Sie sagen, Pestizide sind überall?
Es kann durchaus sein, dass man
auch mit relativ geringer Belastung,
wenn sie über einen langen Zeitraum
besteht, Probleme bekommen kann.
* Belebte Klänge *
(Mann) Der Konsument
muss sich bewusst sein,
dass es ist keine
heilige Landwirtschaft ist,
so wie es z.T. in der Werbung
dargestellt wird
von den Grossverteilern.
Pestizide sind eine Realität.
Auch im biologischen Anbau werden
Pflanzenschutzmittel eingesetzt.
Natürlich weniger,
und es sind biologische Mittel.
Wir sind auf einem Rapsfeld.
Hier werden Pestizide eingesetzt, die
sehr schädlich für die Umwelt sind.
Da haben wir ihn schon.
Wer ist das?
- Der Stängelrüssler.
Der ist in den letzten Wochen
zugeflogen.
Er legt seine Eier
in den Stängel rein.
Das hat zur Folge,
dass der Stängel platzt.
Dann sprechen wir
von einem Ertragsverlust
von 20 bis vielleicht 40 %.
Erst wenn viele Schädlinge auftreten,
darf ein Bauer Pestizid spritzen.
Hier sieht man schön den Einstich,
wie es hier noch raustropft.
Wäre er Biobauer,
könnte Michael Frauenfelder
den Stängelrüssler nicht bekämpfen.
Sein Ertrag würde schwanken
und damit auch sein Lohn.
Viel einfacher geht es
mit synthetischen Pestiziden.
Es ist für uns eine Versicherung,
damit wir einen Ertrag haben.
Ein sicherer Ertrag -
zu einem hohen Preis.
Heute spritzen wir Talstar, ein
Pyrethroid gegen den Stängelrüssler.
Das heisst vermutlich "krebserregend"
und das hier
"Sehr giftig für Wasserlebewesen
mit langanhaltender Wirkung".
- Genau.
Es ist nicht unbedenklich,
das einzusetzen.
Es geht nicht nur
um die Wassertiere.
Es geht auch um andere Insekten
auf dem Feld.
Wir bekämpfen primär
den Stängelrüssler.
Es trifft wahrscheinlich
aber auch andere Insekten,
dieses Mittel.
Das ist ganz klar.
Hat man ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn man das einsetzt?
Ja ...
Es ist nicht so,
dass ich in eine Selbstfindungsphase
gerate, bevor ich spritzen gehe.
Man geht aufs Feld, wir haben das.
Spritze ich nicht, habe ich
einen solchen Ertragsverlust,
dass ich es
auch hätte lassen können.
* Mysteriöse, perlende Klänge *
Rund 60 km entfernt -
ein Bach, stellvertretend für viele,
inmitten intensiver Landwirtschaft.
(Frau) Der Eschelisbach
ist ziemlich pestizidbelastet.
Man hat beinahe 90
verschiedene Pestizide gefunden.
Die Werte
werden z.T. stark überschritten.
Ja, das stellte man leider fest.
2014 der Schock:
massenhaft tote Bachflohkrebse und
Köcherfliegenlarven wegen Pestiziden.
Ein Teil des Bachs: tot.
Im letzten Jahrzehnt
ist die Fangquote von Bachforellen
schweizweit um 40 % geschrumpft.
Durch den Klimawandel
steigen die Wassertemperaturen.
Und je wärmer der Bach,
desto stärker werden Fische
durch Pestizide geschädigt,
sagt Biologin Inge Werner.
Die Fische, die bei 15 °C
Pestizide abbekommen haben,
haben wesentlich stärker
negativ reagiert als die Fische,
die z.B. bei 12 °C
den Pestiziden ausgesetzt waren.
Weil sie zum Schwimmen
mehr Energie gebraucht haben.
Das sind Effekte, die sich
langfristig dann doch auswirken
auf den Fisch: Er hat
schlechtere Überlebenschancen.
Für Kleintiere im Bach
sind die Pestizide,
die auch im Raps gespritzt werden,
am gefährlichsten.
Es sind Pyrethroide - Nervengifte.
Viele können sich
gar nicht vorstellen,
wie wenig es braucht,
um so ein Tierchen zu schädigen.
Wir sind im Gramm-pro-Liter-Bereich.
Wenn Sie da an die neunte Stelle
hinter dem Komma gehen,
sind Sie im Nanogrammbereich.
Nanogramm pro Liter.
Und das reicht schon,
um Schädigungen zu verursachen.
Deshalb muss man wirklich sagen:
"Jeder Tropfen zählt."
Neben dem Bach
bauen wir keinen Raps mehr an.
Ich verwende Antidriftdüsen
und Innenreinigung,
ich achte darauf,
dass es nicht windig ist.
Damit mache ich
aus meiner Sicht alles richtig.
Die Auflagen sind streng.
Aber eine Untersuchung des WWF
vor vier Jahren
im St. Galler Rheintal zeigte:
20 % der Bauern hielten den Abstand
zu Gewässern nicht ein.
Der Bund hat ein Bienengift verboten.
Es lag direkt auf den Rapssamen,
musste also nicht gespritzt werden.
Ersetzt wurde das Bienengift ...
... durch Pyrethroide.
Wenn ich so breitflächig gegen
den Rapserdfloh spritzen muss,
erwische ich auch die,
die sich neben dem Raps befinden -
Nützlinge sowie Schädlinge.
Vieles von dem,
was da kreucht und fleucht,
kennen wir auch nicht.
Aber die kriegen damit
natürlich auch aufs Dach.
Hat man den Teufel
mit dem Beelzebub ausgetrieben?
Das trifft es ziemlich gut.
Und ... Ja, man könnte ...
Wie ist das für Sie - emotional?
Das stellt keine Lösung dar.
Definitiv nicht.
Die Forscherinnen untersuchen
Leber und Hirn der Bachforellen
auch auf Pyrethroide.
Wenn ihre Nerven die Impulse
nicht richtig weiterleiten,
führt das zu Desorientierung.
Die Organismen können sich
nicht mehr richtig bewegen,
sind unkoordiniert
und irgendwann sterben sie.
* Silbrige Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht, weshalb wir so viel
Raps anbauen müssen in der Schweiz.
Ist es das wert,
die Umwelt so stark zu belasten,
um diesen Raps zu kriegen?
Schweizer Rapsöl
wird speziell beworben -
im Gegensatz zu Sonnenblumenöl.
Dabei können Sonnenblumen praktisch
ohne Pestizide angebaut werden.
Rund um den mit Pestiziden
belasteten Eschelisbach
stehen auch viele Obstkulturen.
Bedroht durch:
zehn verschiedene Schädlinge,
dazu Pilz- und Bakterienkrankheiten.
Roland Kreis arbeitet für den
grössten Thurgauer Apfelproduzenten.
Welche Pestizide verwenden wir heute?
Wir verwenden heute SA Slick.
Das Kontaktfungizid Captan.
Wie viele verschiedene Mittel?
Das sind ...
... zwei, vier, sechs,
sieben verschiedene Mittel.
Sieben Mittel für eine Spritzung?
Da kommt noch Blattdünger hinzu.
Dann Bioaktivatoren
und das Insektizid.
Es sind vier Pestizide.
Drei davon schützen die Apfelbäume
vor den Pilzkrankheiten
Schorf und Mehltau.
Wie viele Spritzungen sind nötig,
bis ein Apfel erntereif ist?
Ca. 18-20 Spritzungen.
Ginge es nicht mit weniger?
Weniger ...
Dann müssen wir Schorf
oder Mehltau in Kauf nehmen.
Das wollen und können wir nicht.
Also Pilze?
- Pilzkrankheiten.
V.a. Pilze.
Oder auch Lagerkrankheiten.
Denn unsere Äpfel müssen z.T.
bis zu einem Jahr überdauern.
D.h., sie müssen lagerbar sein.
Haben wir
zu hohe Qualitätsanforderungen?
Auch.
Wäre er Biobauer,
würde Roland Kreis die Äpfel
etwa doppelt so oft spritzen,
weil die Mittel
weniger regenfest sind.
Sie sind zwar weniger schädlich,
aber er müsste mehr Traktor fahren
und würde mehr Diesel verbrauchen.
Ist das der Giftschrank
im Giftschrank?- Richtig.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen
ist das Insektizid ...
Ich nenne es nicht Gift,
sondern Insektizid.
Denn das ist
aus meiner Sicht etwas humaner.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Aber das, was wir verwenden,
ist ein Bienengift.
Richtig.
Deshalb spritzen wir erst,
wenn abgeblüht ist.
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Das spritzen wir nicht,
wenn die Bienen ...
Aber wenn man diese Zeichen
anschaut - gibt Ihnen das zu denken,
dass das sehr giftig ist
für Wasserorganismen
und sogar das Kind im Mutterleib
schädigen kann?
Das ist ...
Das müssen sie
sicherheitshalber machen.
Ich ...
Darauf gebe ich jetzt wirklich ...
Doch, man muss es beachten.
Als Obstbauern sind wir die Letzten,
die so etwas ausbringen möchten -
damit man das auf die Obstbauern
zurückführen kann.
Diese Mittel kann man auch nur
während einer bestimmten Dauer ...
Aber gibt es Ihnen zu denken
oder ist das einfach normal?
Ich glaube,
auf dem Spülmittel der Hausfrau,
wenn man sich das anschaut,
da könnten die gleichen Symbole
abgebildet sein.
Sehr giftig für Wasserlebewesen
und kann ...
Das vielleicht nicht.
- ... das Kind im Mutterleib ...
Ich wäre auch vorsichtig damit,
es herumstehen zu lassen, wenn ...
Gut, man muss das ja nicht trinken.
Das Bienengift
ist unterdessen verboten.
Roland Kreis hat vor 45 Jahren
als Obstbauer begonnen.
Damals trug man Handschuhe
und eine Schürze. Sonst nichts.
Angst vor Krankheiten?
Langzeitschäden?
Habe ich nicht.
Ich fühle mich gesund.
Nicht mehr wie 20, aber ...
Es gibt Studien,
die sagen, dass ein Bauer -
egal, welches Pestizid er
über längere Zeit einsetzt -
ein um 50 % erhöhtes Parkinsonrisiko
hat.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich kenne keinen Bauern mit ...
Es kommt darauf an.
Wenn einer mit 85 ...
An irgendetwas muss man sterben.
Ich habe keine Angst.
* Düstere, sirrende Klänge *
Dieser Cocktail
wird auf die Apfelbäume gespritzt.
Der Handel befiehlt -
und wir als Konsumentinnen
und Konsumenten.
Ist ein Apfel nicht perfekt, verliert
der Bauer zwei Drittel der Einnahmen.
Zwei Klassen:
erste Klasse,
voll ausgebildet, schöne rote Farbe.
Hier haben wir eine ...
Ich habe gesehen,
dass er eine Delle hat.
Und er ist auch leicht grünlich.
Aber es braucht wahnsinnig wenig
für einen Klassenwechsel.
Sehr.
Ist der Handel eher zu streng?
- Der Handel ist sicher strenger.
Strenger als früher, ganz sicher.
Und wie viele Pestizidrückstände
sind im geernteten Apfel?
Das ist die Ampelregelung -
die wir befolgen wir,
damit am Schluss bei der Ernte
die Rückstände
nicht mehr ... erhebbar sind.
Es dürfen nur noch
vier Wirkstoffe darauf sein.
Es müssen nicht vier sein. Es können
auch nur einer oder zwei sein.
Es dürfen nicht mehr als vier sein.
- Ja.
D.h., hier sieht man ganz genau,
wann man was spritzen darf?- Ja.
Diese Mittel ...
Die grünen sind absolut unbedenklich
bis drei Wochen vor der Ernte.
Bei den roten muss man bereits nach
der Blüte aufhören mit dem Spritzen.
Woher stammt das?
Das stammt von ...
... Pflanzenschutzberatern,
in Kombination
mit den Lagerhaltern Tobi.
Ist der Rat der Pestizidhersteller
sehr wichtig für Sie?
Ja, sicher.
Auf sie müssen wir uns ja abstützen.
Die Behörden bestimmen, welche Menge
Gift ein Apfel enthalten darf,
ohne dass wir geschädigt werden.
Der Apfel macht aber nur einen
kleinen Teil unserer Nahrung aus.
Was heisst das für unsere Gesundheit?
Seit dieser Recherche habe ich
mehrheitlich auf Bio umgestellt.
Hallo. Wir haben von Ihnen
eine Urinprobe erhalten.
Von den acht
untersuchten Parametern
konnten wir tatsächlich auch
vier Parameter positiv nachweisen.
Es ist um den Faktor 10 geringer
als das,
was den oberen Bereich der
allgemeinen Bevölkerung ausmacht.
Also eine
sehr moderate Belastung.
Heisst das,
dass das nicht schädlich ist?
Oder was sagt mein Wert
über die Schädigung aus?
Das Vergleichen
mit der Allgemeinbevölkerung
gibt nur wieder,
wo Sie statistisch liegen.
Es ist keine Grössenordnung für
eine toxikologische Beurteilung.
Dies, weil es
noch zu wenige Daten dazu gibt,
wie sich Pestizide
im Menschen verhalten.
Bei der Zulassung untersuchen die
Behörden nur ein einzelnes Pestizid
statt des Cocktails,
den wir zu uns nehmen.
Gerade diese Mischbelastung
ist ein Thema.
Da stehen wir noch ganz am Anfang.
Wenn wir für die verschiedenen
Stoffe Grenzwerte haben,
wissen wir in vielen Fällen noch
nicht, wie sie miteinander wirken.
Ob sie sich potenzieren
oder addieren,
all diese Aspekte
sind oft nicht gut untersucht.
Ist das Ganze eine Blackbox,
diese Pestizidzulassung?
Das gilt durchaus.
Blackbox Pestizidzulassung.
Im Keller
des Bundesamts für Landwirtschaft
lagern über 1'000 Ordner.
Es sind Sicherheitsstudien,
finanziert und in Auftrag gegeben
von Pestizidherstellern.
Rund 175 Gesuche
werden jährlich eingereicht.
Am aufwendigsten
sind Gesuche für neue Wirkstoffe.
Bis zu 80 Bundesordner mit rund
70'000 Seiten an Daten pro Gesuch,
wie einer der Hersteller sagt.
Gerade mal 5,2 Vollzeitstellen
prüfen die Studien
auf Risiken für die Menschen.
Das vergleichbare Österreich beschäf-
tigt doppelt so viele Toxikologen.
Man sei überfordert,
sagte mir eine Quelle
aus dem Inneren des Bundesamts.
Die Giftstudien sind vertraulich.
Geschäftsgeheimnis
der Pestizidhersteller.
Nur die Behörden
haben den vollen Einblick.
Und auch ihre Berichte sind geheim.
* Düstere Klänge *
Das Bundesamt für Landwirtschaft:
seit Anfang Jahr nicht mehr zuständig
für die Zulassung von Pestiziden.
Zu grosse Nähe
zu den Interessen der Bauern,
befand der Bundesrat.
Er transferierte die Verantwortung
zum Bundesamt für Lebensmittel-
sicherheit und Veterinärwesen.
Und hier will niemand ein Interview
vor der Kamera geben -
trotz mehrmaliger Nachfrage
und trotz des Verweises
auf das grosse öffentliche Interesse.
Dabei wurde den Behörden
in einem Bericht der KPMG 2019
mangelnde Transparenz vorgeworfen.
Deutschland und Frankreich veröffent-
lichen ihre Berichte zu Pestiziden
seit Jahren.
Warum tut das die Schweiz nicht?
Per Mail schreibt das Bundesamt,
es gebe keine rechtliche Grundlage.
Dabei könnte die Behörde
selbst Änderungen anregen.
Interne Protokolle zeigen nämlich:
Schon 2017 wollten einige Beamte
Pestizidberichte
der Bevölkerung zugänglich machen.
Jemand anderes aber meinte,
dass das ...
Diese Dokumente konnte ich dank
dem Öffentlichkeitsgesetz verlangen.
Und was sagt die Zulassungsstelle
zum Risiko von Pestizid-Cocktails?
In der Mail schreibt sie:
Die Beamten
verweisen auf zwei EU-Studien.
Diese besagen, dass Pestizid-
Cocktails weder schädlich sind
für die Schilddrüse
noch fürs Nervensystem.
Allerdings:
Auswirkungen auf andere Organe
oder auf das Immunsystem aber
sind unbekannt.
Kein Grund
für eine generelle Entwarnung,
sagten mir drei Toxikologen.
Wenn man eine Mischung
von 100 verschiedenen Stoffen hat
und man nicht bei allen Stoffen
den Grenzwert ausschöpft,
kommt man ganz klar
in die Grössenordnung,
wo Effekte auftreten.
Von daher wundert mich
diese Aussage durchaus.
Wozu haben wir den Staat?
Er reguliert die Pestizide.
Dann könnte man einfach sagen:
"Ich kann essen, was ich will."
Ja, das Problem ist,
dass der Staat
mehrere Schutzziele betrachten muss:
zum einen das Schutzziel
der Gesundheit der Bevölkerung,
zum anderen das Schutzziel
der Ernährbarkeit der Bevölkerung,
dass genügend Nahrungsmittel
zur Verfügung stehen.
Der Staat ist im Dilemma. Und er ist
nicht nur auf unserer Seite.- Ja.
Wie stark ist die Bevölkerung
mit Pestiziden
und anderen Chemikalien belastet?
Die Behörden wissen es nicht.
Eine Pilotstudie läuft.
Im EU-Vergleich
liegen wir Jahre zurück.
Es gibt Zeiten, in denen ich
die Gartenarbeit nicht machen kann.
Ich spüre meine Finger nicht mehr.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Félix Dorsaz, 69.
In den 1980er- und 1990er-Jahren
war er Bauer und spritzte Pestizide.
Davor hatte er
in einer Salzmine gearbeitet
und einmal im Jahr
mit giftigen Stoffen hantiert.
2012 die Diagnose: Parkinson.
Was denken Sie,
ist der Grund Ihrer Krankheit?
Ah ...
Chemische Produkte.
Ob Pestizide schuld sind,
weiss ich nicht.
Aber diese Mittel
haben schon ihre Wirkung.
Zwar gibt es keinen direkten Beweis,
dass man wegen einem
bestimmten Pestizid krank wird,
aber wenn ich an den Cocktail denke,
dem ich ausgesetzt war ...
Und in Frankreich ist Parkinson
eine anerkannte Berufskrankheit
bei Bauern.
Die Schweiz aber
hat keine Gesundheitsdaten zu Bauern.
Das Staatssekretariat für Wirtschaft
verweist auf ausländische Studien.
Wer beruflich irgendeinem Pestizid
ausgesetzt ist,
habe ein mind. 50 % höheres Risiko,
an Parkinson zu erkranken.
Schon als Jugendlicher
half Félix Dorsaz seinem Vater
beim Ausbringen von Pestiziden,
in den 1960er-Jahren.
Ich habe meinem Vater geholfen,
indem ich den Traktor fuhr.
Er sass hinten mit einer Art Lanze,
mit der er spritzte.
Ich war vorne
und steuerte den Traktor.
Praktisch ungeschützt
hätten sie das längst verbotene
Pestizid Paraquat gespritzt.
Paraquat steht im Verdacht,
das Risiko einer Parkinsonerkrankung
zu erhöhen.
Vielleicht habe er sich
schon als Kind vergiftet.
Haben Sie
mit Ihrem Vater darüber gesprochen?
Ja.
Aber ich habe meinen Vater und meine
Mutter im Gespräch unterbrochen
und ihnen gesagt:
"Ihr seid nicht verantwortlich."
Ich sagte: "Den Schuldigen
muss man nicht bei euch suchen."
Wer ist verantwortlich?
Die Agrochemie und die Behörden?
Auf jeden Fall.
Mit der freundlichen Unterstützung
und dem Segen der Detailhändler.
Félix Dorsaz, der einzige Bauer,
der bereit war,
vor der Kamera
über seine Krankheit zu sprechen.
In der Deutschschweiz habe ich drei
andere an Parkinson erkrankte Bauern
angefragt.
Keiner wollte darüber reden.
Jeder zeigt mit dem Finger
auf den anderen:
der Bauer auf den Handel,
der Handel auf den Konsumenten,
der Konsument auf die Agrochemie,
die Agrochemie auf die Behörden.
Die Bundesbehörden
bewilligen die Pestizide.
Es ist an ihnen,
Auflagen zu verfügen,
dass die Gifte
keinen Schaden anrichten.
(Originalton) SRF 1 ...
Nun verbietet die Schweiz das Pilz-
vernichtungsmittel Chlorothalonil.
Chlorothalonil.
Dieser Stoff kann ab einer gewissen
Konzentration krebserregend wirken.
(Urs Gredig)
Verunreinigt mit Pestiziden.
In der Schweiz muss das Trinkwasser
für 1 Mio. Menschen
neu aufbereitet werden.
Das hat allgemein bei uns, auch
wenn ich mit Berufskollegen spreche,
Fragen aufgeworfen.
Diese Fungizidrückstände
im Grundwasser.
Wir spritzen das seit
plus/minus 40 Jahren - oder länger.
Entschuldigung,
hat das nie jemand überprüft?
Das hat uns Bauern
natürlich betroffen.
Das Chlorothalonil?
- Genau.
Kantonschemiker wie Kurt Seiler
kontrollieren das Grundwasser
auf Abbauprodukte von Pestiziden.
Sie sind dafür verantwortlich, dass
unser Trinkwasser einwandfrei ist.
Wieso haben Sie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten nicht Alarm geschlagen?
Das Problem sind die Abbauprodukte
beim Chlorothalonil.
Wir wussten gar nicht,
dass es diese gibt.
Wir wussten auch nicht,
welche es gibt.
Denn diese Information
hat nur die Zulassungsstelle
resp. der Pestizidhersteller.
Vor zehn Jahren hat Kurt Seiler
deshalb dem Bund geschrieben.
Gestützt auf das
Öffentlichkeitsgesetz
verlangte er Auskunft über
die Abbauprodukte heikler Pestizide.
Wie lautete die Antwort?
Der Aufwand, uns das zur Verfügung
zu stellen, sei zu gross.
Diese Dossiers seien zu umfangreich.
Das sei nicht möglich.
U.a. auch aufgrund des Geschäfts-
geheimnisses der Pestizidhersteller.
Was fühlten Sie, als
das Bundesamt für Landwirtschaft
so antwortete?
- Ohnmacht.
Wir haben den Auftrag,
das in der Umwelt zu kontrollieren.
Da darf es kein Geschäftsgeheimnis
geben aus meiner Sicht.
Letztlich ging dieses Zögern
zulasten der Bevölkerung.
Was sagt die Zulassungsstelle
zu dieser Kritik?
Nichts.
Auch auf Nachfrage nicht.
Sie schreibt nur, im
Verhältnis Bund und Kantone sei ...
Besondere Regelungen?
Staatsrechtler sagen, es gelte die
Bundesverfassung und der Grundsatz:
Es war ein Dauerkampf ...
... um Informationen.
Zehn Jahre lang?
- Ja.
Das erste Pestizid
mit dem Wirkstoff Chlorothalonil,
zugelassen 1970.
Zwei Jahre bevor Pestizide schweiz-
weit überhaupt reguliert wurden.
Der Bund
hatte damals noch keine Toxikologen
und zog externe Spezialisten bei.
Er habe Pestizidstudien
gratis in seiner Freizeit
für den Bund beurteilt,
sagt Christian Schlatter,
damals tätig beim toxikologischen
Institut der ETH und Uni Zürich.
Pro Stoff habe er
rund 10 Std. gebraucht.
Erst 1982 stellte der Bund
einen Toxikologen an,
um Schlatter zu unterstützen.
Schlatter sagte damals,
bei zugelassenen Pestiziden
bestehe keine Krebsgefahr.
Pflanzenschutzmittel,
die Krebs erzeugen könnten,
werden gar nicht zugelassen.
Sie werden vorher durch intensive
Untersuchungen an Modellsystemen
und im Tierexperiment auf
ihre Krebswirksamkeit abgeklärt.
Sollten sie positiv sein,
kommen sie gar nicht auf den Markt.
Im Fall von Chlorothalonil aber
wies schon damals eine Studie
auf die Krebsgefahr hin.
1978 schrieb das amerikanische
Krebsforschungsinstitut:
Schon 40 Jahre vor dem Verbot schrieb
das Institut, Chlorothalonil sei ...
Damals aber reichte das nicht aus,
um ein Pestizid zu verbieten.
Vergleichbar mit der Gefahr
durch einen Hai,
der in grosser Distanz
zum Menschen schwimmt.
Erst bei einem Risiko,
erst wenn der Hai
direkt auf einen Menschen zuschwimmt
und der Mensch
gefressen werden könnte,
wurde ein Pestizid verboten.
Seit 2011 aber gelten strengere
Regeln in der EU und der Schweiz.
Jetzt reicht die Gefahr,
dass ein Hai anwesend ist,
unabhängig von der Distanz,
um ein Pestizid zu verbieten.
D.h., es wird verboten,
wenn es als "wahrscheinlich
krebserregend" eingestuft wird.
Seit dem Paradigmenwechsel
wurde Chlorothalonil
erst 2016 überprüft
und erst 2019 verboten.
Herstellerin Syngenta
hat gegen das Verbot geklagt.
Sie wehrt sich gegen die Einstufung
"wahrscheinlich krebserregend".
Gibt es weitere heikle Pestizide
im Trinkwasser?
Das wird jetzt abgeklärt.
Der Bund publiziert unterdessen
einen Teil der Pestizidabbaustoffe.
Aufgrund des Drucks der Kantone.
Auch die Politik macht Druck.
Das Pestizidrisiko muss
bis in fünf Jahren halbiert werden,
im Vergleich zur Situation
vor zehn Jahren.
Warum ist aber überhaupt
so viel Pestizid im Bach?
Die Zulassungsstelle
müsste das Gift doch so regulieren,
dass es keinen Schaden anrichtet.
Die Antwort verblüfft:
Die Behörden berücksichtigen
zwei wichtige Eintragswege
für Pestizide im Gewässer
bei der Zulassung nicht.
In der Nähe der Felder stehen
schweizweit über 1 Mio. Schächte.
Wenn es nach dem Spritzen regnet,
werden Pestizidrückstände
über Leitungen und Entwässerungsrohre
in Bäche geschwemmt.
Rund ein Drittel
der Pestizidmenge im Bach
stammt von diesen zwei Eintragswegen.
Man sei dabei, Gegenmassnahmen
abzuklären, heisst es beim Bund.
Das meiste Gift im Gewässer aber
stammt vom Bauernhof.
Einige Bauern wuschen ihre Spritzen
früher auf dem Hofplatz,
ohne Pestizidrückstände aufzufangen.
Das Gift kam so
via Schächte ins Gewässer.
Roland Kreis' Firma
hat darum vor drei Jahren
einen unterirdischen Auffangtank
gebaut.
Haben Sie gewusst, dass diese
Geschichte ein Problem ist?- Nein.
Man hat dem
zu wenig Beachtung geschenkt,
man hatte die Kenntnis nicht.
Sie wussten das vorher nicht?
- Nein.
Aber das Bundesamt für Umwelt
gab 2013 schon
Vollzugsrichtlinien heraus.
Sie schrieben,
dass es eine Auffangwanne braucht.
Wissen Sie, was das gekostet hat?
Das hat uns ca. 15'000 Fr. gekostet.
Das kann man nicht
von einem Jahr aufs andere ...
Man kann schon, aber
die Vorschriften kamen mit der Zeit.
Man soll doch
eins nach dem anderen machen,
nicht etwas
mit dem Holzhammer erzwingen.
Wir haben das Gewässerschutzgesetz
seit den 90er-Jahren.
Dort steht, dass kein fremder Stoff,
der gefährlich sein kann,
direkt oder indirekt
in ein Gewässer gelangen darf.
Darauf achten wir auch.
Erst vor zwei Jahren
haben die ersten Kantone begonnen,
die Waschplätze
der Bauern zu kontrollieren.
Zu unserer Entschuldigung: Man hatte
keinen Druck, das stimmt schon.
Jeder schaute selbst, wie gut
oder wo er seine Spritzen wäscht.
Das stimmt schon.
Warum aber
kommt der Druck erst jetzt?
Seit 30 Jahren steht im Gesetz,
dass keine verunreinigenden Stoffe
in Gewässer gelangen dürfen.
Die Sensibilität, dass das einen
bedeutenden Beitrag leisten könnte,
war zweifelsohne nicht da.
Das BAFU gab schon 2013 zusammen
mit dem Bundesamt für Landwirtschaft
eine Vollzugshilfe heraus,
in der es folgenden Punkt gab:
Die Waschplätze
müssen angeschaut und saniert werden.
Okay.
Das sagt Ihnen nichts?
- Nein.
Jetzt im Nachhinein
kann man sich fragen:
Wir haben dieses Gewässerschutzgesetz
seit 1992.
Wenn viele Kantone
das bis jetzt nie angeschaut haben,
ist es ja nicht vollzogen worden?
Im Gewässerschutzrecht
gibt es so viele Bestimmungen ...
Sie haben beschränkte Ressourcen.
Man hätte
diesen punktuellen Einträgen
sicher mehr Aufmerksamkeit
schenken können.
Das kann man schon sagen.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Das ist die Liste der Pestizide,
die 1989 bewilligt waren,
als ich für die Migros produzierte.
* Beklemmende Musik *
Zwei Drittel dieser Pestizide
sind heute verboten -
zu gefährlich
für die Umwelt und die Menschen.
Auch das Nervengift Chlorpyrifos.
Es dauerte aber mehr
als ein halbes Jahrhundert,
bis die Behörden
das Gift verboten hatten.
Das erste Pestizid mit Chlorpyrifos
wurde 1976 provisorisch zugelassen.
Aufgrund von welchen Studien?
Die Zulassungsstelle weiss es nicht.
Erst 20 Jahre später,
erst in den 1990er-Jahren,
wurde an jungen Ratten untersucht,
wie das Gift auf die
Gehirnentwicklung von Embryos wirkt.
Die amerikanische Herstellerfirma
Dow AgroSciences
fasste die Resultate der Studie
zusammen:
D.h.: keine Gefahr für den Menschen.
Zehn Jahre später aber
ist alles anders:
Wissenschaftler
warnen in mehreren Studien
vor Gehirnanomalien bei Kindern.
Die EU bezweifelt die Aussagekraft
dieser Studien zunächst.
Und so dauert es weitere acht Jahre,
bis sie das Nervengift
2020 verbietet.
Auch wegen der Erkenntnisse
eines deutschen Chemikers,
der in Schweden lebt.
Auf dem Weg zu ihm frage ich mich:
Brauchte es wirklich ein halbes
Jahrhundert, um herauszufinden,
dass Chlorpyrifos
Kinder schädigen kann?
Nein, sagt Axel Mie.
Er schaffte es, an die geheime Studie
von Chlorpyrifos heranzukommen.
Was haben Sie denn herausgefunden?
Der Pestizidhersteller
hat eine falsche Zusammenfassung
der Zulassungsstudie
an die Behörden eingereicht.
Ich habe
anhand der Rohdaten herausgefunden,
dass die Entwicklung der Gehirne
der Rattenjungen geschädigt ist,
schon bei der kleinsten
getesteten Dosis Chlorpyrifos.
Das zeigt aber
weder der Testbericht
noch die
Zusammenfassung des Herstellers.
D.h.: Schon die kleinste Menge
Chlorpyrifos kann Kinder schädigen.
Was war Ihr erster Gedanke,
als Sie das herausfanden?
Ich sass in meinem Büro
und war ziemlich geschockt.
Chlorpyrifos hätte 1998 also
gar nicht zugelassen werden dürfen?
Genau. Entweder
hätte es 1998 verboten werden müssen
oder der Gebrauch hätte stark
eingeschränkt werden müssen.
Und warum merkten das
die Zulassungsbehörden nicht?
Sie nahmen sich wohl nicht die Zeit,
diese 800-900 Seiten durchzulesen.
Sie hätten bis Seite 664 lesen
und die entsprechenden statistischen
Analysen machen müssen.
Dann hätten sie den Effekt gefunden,
den ich identifiziert habe.
Ein Insider der Schweizer Behörden
bestätigt:
Wenn die Zeit dränge, lese man nur
die Zusammenfassungen der Hersteller
statt der detaillierten Studien.
Die Preisfrage ist:
Ist das ein trauriger Einzelfall
oder nur die Spitze des Eisbergs?
Ich denke, es ist kein Einzelfall.
Der Hersteller
hat immer ein Interesse daran,
dass die eigenen Produkte
sicher wirken,
damit er so viel wie möglich
davon verkaufen kann.
D.h., das Zulassungssystem
kann heute nicht sicher verhindern,
dass wir geschädigt werden?
- Korrekt.
Das ist doch schockierend.
- Das ist schockierend.
Was sagt die Zulassungsstelle
zu diesem Vorwurf?
Nichts Konkretes.
Auf Bitte um Präzisierung
nochmals derselbe Wortlaut:
Intern aber
wird die Verordnung kritisiert:
Der Gesundheitsschutz sei in Gefahr,
heisst es
in der neuen Zulassungsstelle.
Dies,
weil die Verordnung verändert wurde -
auf Antrag der alten Zulassungsstel-
le, dem Bundesamt für Landwirtschaft.
Früher waren Pestizide
nämlich nur befristet bewilligt.
Gleich wie in der EU.
Art. 19 aber wurde 2019 gestrichen.
Seither
sind Pestizide für immer zugelassen.
Zwar können Teilbereiche
überprüft werden,
aber dafür bekommen die Toxikologen
keine vollständigen Datenpakete mehr.
In internen Protokollen klagen sie,
die Datenlage sei:
Die Aufgaben des Gesundheitsschutzes
können nur mit vollständigen
und transparenten Unterlagen
erfolgen.
Überprüfte Pestizide
werden oft strenger reguliert.
Im Vergleich
zur Datenfülle der EU aber
fühlen sich die Toxikologen
im Blindflug.
Sie wollen die Verordnung
wieder verschärfen.
* Unstete Klänge *
Guten Morgen.
Das Nervengift Chlorpyrifos aber, das
Kinder schädigen kann, ist verboten -
könnte man meinen.
Ernst,
von der Lebensmittelkontrolle.
Haben Sie Chili oder Ähnliches?
Trotz des Verbots kommt das Gift
weiterhin in die Schweiz.
Es ist heute Chili aus Thailand.
In jeder dritten Lebensmittelprobe
aus Asien ist zu viel Pestizid.
Z.B. Chlorpyrifos,
oder andere Pestizide,
die in der Schweiz verboten sind.
Im Zürcher Kantonslabor leitet An-
dreas Schürmann die Pestizidanalyse.
So.
Er fand das Nervengift Chlorpyrifos
2020 in jeder siebten Probe.
In 21 Proben war die Menge so hoch,
dass das Lebensmittel
gesundheitsschädigend war.
D.h., Sie würden schwangeren Frauen
dringend davon abraten,
Früchte oder Gemüse aus Asien
zu essen?
Ja, die Gefahr eines Risikos
ist zu gross.
Die neurotoxischen Effekte
auf das ungeborene Kind
sind das grösste Problem.
Mit Stickstoff
werden die Proben gefroren.
Händler mit gesundheitsschädigender
Ware werden nicht gesperrt.
Andreas Schürmann
fehlt die gesetzliche Grundlage.
Fehlbare Händler
könne er nur zwingen,
ihre Ware vor dem Verkauf zu testen.
Und er reicht Strafanzeige ein.
Die Bussen aber seien gering,
rund 2'000 Fr.
Wenn man mit Herzblut dabei ist
und sieht,
dass Dinge aus dem Ruder laufen,
tut das natürlich weh.
Eines der Probleme, die wir haben:
Wir hinken immer hinterher.
Wir übernehmen die EU-Rechte,
und wenn die EU etwas festlegt,
schaut die Schweiz das an
und übernimmt es später.
Wir hinken immer hinterher.
Bei Chlorpyrifos dauerte es ein Jahr,
bis die Schweiz
die strengeren EU-Werte übernahm.
Solange waren auch
als gesundheitsschädigend
geltende Lebensmittel im Umlauf.
Bei toxikologisch begründeten Sachen
muss man viel strenger
und viel schneller sein
und darf keine oder nur minimale
Übergangsfristen erlauben,
damit man auch
den Konsumenten schützen kann.
Der Fokus auf Pestizide allein aber
sei künstlich, sagen Toxikologen.
Eigentlich müssten die Behörden
den ganzen Chemikalienmix regulieren,
dem wir ausgesetzt sind: Plastik,
Schwermetalle,
Flammschutzmittel, Kosmetika etc.
Aber da steht auch die EU
noch ganz am Anfang.
* Dramatische Musik *
(Fernsehsprecher) La Suisse a voté.
Unglaublich.
Wir stossen
mit einem Aprikosenschnaps
von Mitarbeiter Andi an.
Prost, Andi.
- Prost.
Zum Wohl.
- Tobias. Zum Wohl miteinander.
Ihr Frauen.
Haben Sie Angst, dass es künftig
mehr Parkinsonfälle geben wird?
Ich habe keine Angst,
ich bin wütend.
Es ist Wut, dass es Leute gibt,
die andere Leute wie mich
in diese Situation bringen.
Und jetzt kann man nicht mehr sagen,
dass man es nicht wusste.
Früher wusste man
vielleicht nicht um die Gefahr,
aber jetzt kennt man sie.
In der Verfassung steht,
dass die Landwirtschaft
unsere Bevölkerung
ernähren können muss.
Das wäre
nicht mehr sichergestellt gewesen
mit einer Annahme
dieser Initiativen.
Wir haben schon jetzt nur einen
Selbstversorgungsgrad von 60 %.
40 % werden importiert.
Das könnte wieder eine Krise geben.
Dass wir nichts mehr bekommen,
dann verhungern die Leute.
Maria.
- Und ich?
Das freut mich wirklich.
Aber es ist auch ein Zeichen
an die Schweizer Landwirtschaft:
40 % der Leute wollen
eine nachhaltige Landwirtschaft.
So oder so - es wird
nicht weitergehen wie vor 20 Jahren.
In keiner Branche
kann man stehen bleiben.
Die Landwirtschaft
bleibt auch nicht stehen.
Aber man kann nicht
von Null auf Hundert etwas ändern,
das geht nicht.
Mit dem Druck der Politik kommen
bestechend einfache Lösungen auf:
Abdecken von Schächten,
damit Pestizide beim Spritzen
nicht in Gewässer gelangen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Seit wann machen Sie das?
- Das ist das erste Jahr.
Und als Alternative zu Pestiziden:
biologische Duftstoffe
gegen Schädlinge.
Die sog. Verwirrungsmethode,
damit das Männchen
das Weibchen nicht findet
und keine Begattung stattfindet.
Sie sind also total verwirrt und
wir haben praktisch keine Schäden.
Im Zürcher Weinland
erntet Michael Frauenfelder
seinen Raps zum letzten Mal.
Er pflanze keinen neuen mehr an.
Das Pyrethroid, das er gespritzt hat,
darf bald
nicht mehr eingesetzt werden.
Und je weniger Mittel, desto eher
werden Schädlinge resistent.
Gut.
Das Erntejahr 2021 - sehr schlecht,
wegen des vielen Regens.
Auch darum seien Pestizide
nach wie vor nötig, sagt er.
Als Bauer
wird der Spagat immer schwieriger
zwischen
ökologischer Nachhaltigkeit,
Wirtschaftlichkeit
und dem, was der Konsument will.
Es sind viele Spagate
und es ist ein sehr breites Spiel-
feld, auf dem wir momentan stehen.
Ab und zu weiss man als Bauer nicht,
wo man eigentlich hin soll.
Ab diesem Jahr fordert der Handel:
Äpfel müssen
nachhaltiger produziert werden.
Bauern
sollen resistente Sorten anbauen.
D.h.: Äpfel,
die gegen Krankheiten resistent sind
und weniger gespritzt werden müssen.
Das ist diese Sorte, Topaz.
Es ist die bekannteste dieser Art.
Und die muss man weniger spritzen?
- Ja, ein Drittel weniger.
Das bringt wirklich etwas?
- Sicher, ja.
Sie arbeiten für Lidl -
nimmt Lidl nun den Topaz?- Nein.
Sie haben z.T. Nachteile:
Sie können etwas fettig werden,
wenn sie ein paar Tage
im Regal liegen bleiben.
Wie finden Sie das?
- Es ist schleierhaft für mich.
Einerseits schreit man
nach Nachhaltigkeit, Öko.
Andererseits schmeisst man
eine solche Sorte aus dem Sortiment.
Er macht zu wenig Umsatz,
irgend so was.
Da sind sie knallhart.
Da kommt der Profit
vor ökologischem Denken.
Resistente Sorten fordern,
aber nicht verkaufen?
Lidl schreibt:
Aus "wettbewerbstechnischen" Gründen
wolle man nicht sagen,
ob das Sortiment angepasst werde.
Und die umstrittene Gentechnik?
Nicht mal sie würde es schaffen,
den beliebten Gala
ganz ohne Pestizide zu züchten.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Keine perfekte Lösung in Sicht.
Und wir alle
sind Teil des Pestizid-Pokers:
Agrochemie, Behörden,
Bauern, Handel und Konsument.
Es ist an uns,
zu bestimmen, was uns wichtiger ist:
mehr Erntesicherheit
oder mehr Schutz für die Umwelt,
die Tiere und uns Menschen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
E. Graf, M. Riedi - 2022